you say yes why do you think the answer
is yes okay so you're suggesting that
because like we already sort of thought
these are in the same family of
functions like these guys these are not
parabolas but it does work with this
right like we read off B or C C we read
that off as the y-intercept we can do
that right why can't we do it here so
this is suggestions a key no you go
ahead
once we work out what the X's are when
you say work out what the X's are do you
mean these guys yes Zhang keys talking
about making the X is zero and then
solving for y so so you've got a whole
bunch X's here right yeah rest what do
you what do you think okay so hold on a
second III do point out the majority of
you not all of you the majority view
including pressed down voted the idea
that this was the line is that right you
change your mind yeah you were gone back
and forth okay but what you're
suggesting is right cuz is that well you
did you said write it so you're just oh
yeah this is not my idea this is his
idea okay
what we are suggesting it seems is if
you let y equal zero you'll find the x
intercepts weren't you right quick
question why does that work why does y
equal zero why does that give you say
I'm on something give this guy these are
the X intercepts here
why would y equal zero give you the X in
just I remember being so confused about
this when I was I was like why in X are
like swapping around that way
mr. zero them if y equals zero then we
go on to the line which line is surround
to hold that thought sorry which line is
Sarang talking about the x-axis that's
this one here right if there was no axis
labeled on the Cartesian plane right and
you wanted to describe where is the x
axis what would its equation be the
answer is the equation of the x-axis is
this isn't it it's not above it's not
below it's right smack bang in the
middle do you agree
so this finds the x-intercepts second
correct
we we can have like this guy up here
right so letting y equal zero doesn't
always give you solutions but when
you're looking at it from the other
point of view right when you're finding
the y-intercept you let this is what you
were suggested right you let X that's a
messy x equals zero now what happens to
this equation here if x equals zero just
hold that thought I said you had your
thumb up what do you reckon what happens
when I keep doing yeah yeah zero plus or
zero squared actually plus five lots of
zero minus five and because of what
these things are these become they sort
of can be disregarded right which is why
we can sort of just look at that last
number provided of course it's in this
nice neat form do you agree if it's in
this what is what's the name of this by
the way when we have everything like
with the squares in order this it's got
a name I starts with a J its general
form right that's why we actually like
general form it's one of the useful
things about it okay so in fact I'm
pretty sure like a good 2/3 of us said
no that's wrong you can't just look at
that last number but if it's in this
form seems like we can't you had what
Oh ha
so that's really issues you said a bunch
of interesting things here you said like
the original parabola the one we start
off all learning is this guy right and
where is that um what does that sit
right in the middle right so it's we
have a word for this its vertex is at
the origin right so here is okay then
you suggested okay but this minus five
it's it's a shift isn't that's the word
that you use it just moves you up or
down so that intercept there which used
to be at zero
I guess now it will be at five five
beneath that which would be at minus
five right you said that then you said
another really interesting thing which
was you said are you can just ignore
this okay that's a really good question
I'm gonna let you all think about that
it seems that it seems that this works
right why can we just ignore this guy
like you couldn't ignore it like you're
saying wait I just arbitrarily decide
this one's important pay attention to
this guy and just ignore him because
whatever right why doesn't this hmm
that's just I'm not gonna explain that
yet I'm gonna let you think about that
right have a think about it because that
um that raises some really good
questions okay if Sean did you have one
last comment you want to yes hold on
hold on hold on state Alex Davis this
how can this thing right which we were
like oh cool you know like we could do
this thing looking at this end spot and
get the y-intercept out of it how can
this have anything to do with this
context cuz it seems like we're dealing
with entirely different objects doesn't
it right like we're looking at straight
things versus curvy things what is up
with that that's a really good question
to ask and I want you to keep thinking
about it I'm not gonna tell you the
answer just yet
okay can we our wine things back just a
bit okay we got a little bit carried
away we said we're just we haven't even
got past the first item we were trying
to find intercepts right we said if you
want to find the x-intercepts yeah that
y equals 0 once you've done that though
you've got to deal with all the rest of
the stuff on this side of the equation
right so you have a choice you can
either factorize if you have been handed
nice neat numbers sometimes you don't
though you're going to have something
with like square roots and it serves it
cetera so you go to the formula okay I'm
probably worth quickly jotting down the
formula in here just so we have it for
the sake of completeness okay we use the
formula to find out the x-intercepts
that's what it tells us
and then the y-intercept actually wrote
this up here but I should have written
it below to find the wine is that it
seems that when we let X equal zero what
lands on the other end is just this last
number the constant that's all gets left
behind okay so you can find out what the
y-intercept is off that and then you can
put that onto your graph so I'm going to
quickly give you because we've been
thinking about it I'm actually actually
let's just take this one this is a
question that's been on the board for
the doís y equals x squared plus 5x
minus 5 can you go ahead find me some x
and y-intercepts
go ahead work it out and then can you
draw me on the basis of just those three
piece of information can you draw me
what that graph looks like and then we
will after you've had a couple minutes
to do that and I want you to properly
draw it then we'll have a look at these
two can you do that for me give about
three minutes